(upbeat music)
- You know, there's a great Russian saying
that says man thinks and God laughs.
Like as a true operator,
I think about this a lot.
If you actually recognize how
much is out of your control,
the weight of your decisions
dramatically decreases.
People fear changing their
mind out of judgment.
- [Interviewer] How do you
pull out of that decision?
Like if you're--
- Stop worrying about
other people's opinions.
So many of you have
become non changer minders
because you're worried about
other people's opinions.
You must deconstruct this,
because changing your mind
is the ultimate strength.
(uplifting music)
- Garry changed his mind on wine content.
- Gary changed his mind on Zoom calls.
- And numerous hires,
- On media,
- On fitness,
- On daily blogging,
On using AirPods.
- My career,
- On Uber,
- On cam,
- Laptops,
- And LinkedIn.
- Gary changes his mind every day.
- [Katie] Hey guys, I'm Katie.
I'm Gary's influencer
partnerships manager.
In this film, we're trying
something different.
We interviewed a variety
of people in Gary's world
from the time when he sold
baseball cards to the present.
What we'll learn here is
how changing direction
played such a big role in Gary success
and how it affected people around him.
First,
we'll take it to the early
days of Gary's personal brand
in 2016, with Sid.
- My first role on the team was an intern.
I was a summer intern
on team GaryVee in 2015.
And I was really observing
everything around.
Everything that Gary was
making decisions with,
like how he was acting,
how he was communicating with
his employees and everything.
So one of the really big
moments for me was when
I realized that he was always
all in and at the same time,
he was always ready to
say that he was wrong
and wanting to do really pivot.
And that's why I asked him this question
on the "AskGaryVee" show.
I've seen you go all in when
you're like doing something,
but then we also,
as a team I've seen that you step back
and see things in a wider perspective
and then you change direction.
So how do you decide when it's like
moment to just step back and reconsider?
- This question is the
same question of like,
how do you know when to hit the high note?
Like when do you know it's game
time and you've got to shoot
and stop passing the ball?
- His summary of the
answer was really that
it's a very instinctive thing
and it's literally something
that you're born with
and it's not something
you can teach someone.
So in his words,
it's literally something
that you're born with
and that's how you're
just reacting instincts.
And that's why some people are successful,
some people aren't because
even though you're,
you're reacting to these instincts
and there's more of my
understanding of this version.
Even though you're reacting to instincts,
a lot of people that are not comfortable
or insecure enough to
like not to be wrong.
And that's where like
they start questioning
their instincts.
And that's where things really changed
for some of the people.
- I fail every day.
Like the amount of things
that I make decisions on
that don't work out are every day.
I think one of the great
ways to tell the difference
between a winning entrepreneur
and a losing entrepreneur
is how much they enjoy music.
- What Sid observed is that
Gary's ability to change
comes from an instinct he was born with,
but can this be learned?
- My name is Andy Krainak.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk's brand director.
- Andy K, get up here right here.
I got you.
I see you.
Andy's live streaming and he's struggling.
Let's give it up for Andy K.
- I think like the hardest
change for a lot of people
is actually just like a mindset change.
So many people don't want
to post a lot of content.
They just always default into no.
So many people think that
Tiktok doesn't matter,
that it's still for young kids,
and like, I don't think of
the change there being like,
Oh, you're going to go
from not posting on Tiktok
to posting on Tiktok.
I think the change that Gary
really is trying to empower
in minds of people and on his
team and in the organization,
and then his content is
the change of saying yes.
- While everybody's spending 80 hours
trying to figure out the plan
of how to get on the six things,
you're just doing.
Staying active, right?
Just say, yes.
Everybody's saying no.
Everybody saying no to shit.
Cause they think they're being
thoughtful or they're smart,
like you know many people saying no,
that aren't even fancy
enough to say yes yet,
so I just say yes, man, a lot.
- The change of saying
yes to opportunities.
The change of saying yes to
what happens when you publish
and you start learning new muscles.
And that's really what I
challenged myself off of
when I listened to Gary's
content about changing,
is not drawing the lines in the sand
for whatever the case may be
to being open to the
other side of the equation
and feeling what that looks like.
- Everybody's so crippled by decisions,
but you never know how the
other thing worked out.
Let me give you an example.
Let's say you don't go to college,
and you start this business,
and you were a hundred percent right,
and it's huge and you're doing so great,
but because you did that,
you had to fly to
America for a big meeting
and your plane crashed and you died.
That would be a bad idea.
Or you think you're going to go to college
cause it's a good experience
and you'll meet people.
You can meet people in a business.
You're not going to know.
- You know, I think people
are crippled by change
because they feel like
they make a decision
and that's it for the rest of their life,
but you can decide
tomorrow to be an actor,
and the next day decide
you want to be a rapper
and another day decided
you want to be a Tiktoker.
I think all are cool and interesting ideas
as long as you're being
honest with yourself
and you're willing to put in the work
on the change that you say
you're going to make happen.
- Most people fear
changing their mind because
they're worried about what
people will judge them for
when just a year ago they said
I'm going to be a fitness coach,
and then nine months later
they're selling pizzas
and everyone's like,
Oh, you're full of shit.
And it's not about being full of shit.
It's you fucking changed your mind.
- Gary often makes decisions
predicated on his morals
and values.
So let's see how that
translates to his business life.
- One thing Gary, I noticed,
he's not afraid to walk
away from something
that challenges his values.
Like if somebody is going
to ask them to do something
like he's not afraid to change his mind
if it challenges his values.
- I spend no time convincing people
to believe in what I believe in.
- So for me and my job as
new business development hat,
there might be a client that
might be a great opportunity,
but if it's taking us down
to path to do something
that's not something we
would do but what they want,
he is no brainer for him
to walk away from that.
- I like to say yes to everything,
but there are absolutely
moral or concerns.
There's entire business concepts
that I'm just uncomfortable with.
I think everybody should walk
away from certain business
based on their moral compass
and opportunity costs.
- But what I think he
really understands is that
when you change your mind,
that means that you're
willing to hear somebody
and Gary for being somebody who is
one of the loudest speakers I know,
and obviously produces so much content
to get his own message out,
is secretly the best listener.
And I think a lot of people
don't give him credit for that.
- I am a full time listener.
Everybody thinks I talk all the time.
All I'm doing is listening.
The biggest reason I talk so much
is to get reactions from you,
whether one-on-one you
and an audience like this
or the whole fucking
world when I do content,
I talk so much strategically
to get reactions
so I can listen so I can readjust.
- And it's not just hearing,
it's listening,
which is a major difference that's where
you'll see people,
we all know people like this that
you're in a meeting and somebody's just
they are hearing what you have to say,
but they're just waiting until
they have the opportunity
to talk that's where with Gary
it's listening, absorbing,
connecting dots, figuring things out
and then bringing his point,
which you don't always
get with when you're
watching his blog or
he'll say it so often on "AskGaryVee"
when he's got guests and
sometimes he's talking over him
and stuff, so.
- I apologize to interrupt,
but I have to ask you the same question.
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Let me interrupt, I apologize.
- It's the name of the show.
- Thank you very much.
- And not something that you
would think from watching him,
but knowing him personally
and being in meetings with him
and getting to know him so well,
he's an incredible listener
and it's something that I
really admire about him.
- [Katie] Everybody has a story.
In chapter two,
let's take this back to
Gary's best friend, Brandon.
- Literally I'm doing what I
did when I was 16 years old
with this guy, my best
friend, Brandon and Mike,
we're literally doing a show.
Like in an uncomfortable like,
can I muster up the courage
to quit everything I'm doing
and only be a baseball card dealer?
Like that much fun.
- My name is Brandon Warnke.
I met Gary on my first day
of high school in 1990.
We developed a pretty quick friendship.
Currently I'm running the
operations at wine library
and I'm doing a lot of the
buying and sales as well as just,
day to day operations.
Kind of the stuff that Gary was doing here
before he moved on to VaynerMedia.
Gary and I are...
Our friendship really was
built on baseball cards.
It was built on the fact that
we both, we both loved to,
we both loved to buy and sell,
that was number one,
and we both loved baseball cards.
So it was like the
perfect, the perfect combo.
And so for years, that's all that we did.
And it was, it was a real passion.
We had a great time.
There memories that
are irreplaceable and
just unbelievable times.
- At 11 and 12,
I was already going to malls and hotels
and selling baseball cards at shows.
When I was 11 and 12,
I was making a thousand dollars a weekend
selling baseball cards.
How?
I had no money.
My parents had no money.
What did I do?
When it snowed, I went to people's houses,
rang the doorbell and asked
them to give me a dollar to $5
to shovel their yard and they said, yes,
and then I worked for 30 minutes,
shoveled somebody's yard,
got five bucks,
or in the summer I got lemonade.
I set up, I did a lemonade stand.
Like I did things.
I didn't have the internet.
- But there came a
point towards the end of
our high school days, really our junior,
I guess the end of our junior year,
beginning of senior year
where the whole baseball card
market was just drowning,
and it just wasn't very
popular and slowly but surely
during the cards we would do,
there would be some
dealers that would set up
and they'd have half a cake table of cards
and then half a table of comics and toys.
So there was definitely
a shift in the market
and Gary saw it and
despite his real love for baseball cards,
he was very ready to pivot to
wherever the market was going.
And at that point, the
market was going to toys.
And so,
I remember the very last
card show I ever did,
I was already kind of burnt out.
I was already kind of done.
I was spending a lot of money,
not getting any in return,
the card, the value was
worthless it seemed.
And we did this last show,
which was in Hillsborough,
Hillsborough, New Jersey.
And I went to the show and I
walked in and Gary was there
and his entire table was full of toys,
no cards at all, just all toys.
- I didn't tell Brandon
I have his strategy.
See he's setting up his cards,
I start opening up these big boxes,
and some wizard of oz and cat woman toys.
We're juniors in high school.
Brandon looks over, he goes, I'm done.
- And I remember walking up
and I looked at him and I said,
what is this?
And I was kind of upset
because deep down I knew
that was it.
It was over.
Like the baseball card
between us, we're done.
The whole industry was dying.
And he goes,
we're going to sell a ton of toys today.
And I said, not me and I left.
I just, I was not, I couldn't do it.
- I know this is the future.
I literally was like...
and I'm the oldest.
Like in...
I fucking nailed it.
As a set, nobody thought about
Marvel movies and star Wars.
I fucking nailed it.
- I just, I couldn't,
I couldn't change my mind in that moment,
but Gary sure did.
And the rest is history.
They went out and he did toys,
which is where the market
was for quite a while.
Only now with the last three
years that you guys will know
to come full circle back into cards,
where now it seems cards
are the hottest thing going.
I mean, it's just, it's unbelievable.
So that was from cards,
all in on cards,
then all in on toys and
then all back in on cards.
- I believe we're on the,
we're in the second
quarter of four quarters
of the sports card industry
exploding again and culture.
And I think there's a ton of money
and a lot of fun to be made
for a lot of entrepreneurs, kids,
especially sneaker kids
who can't get enough inventory
of hard to get sneakers.
But if they want to go
buy 5,000 Giannis rookies,
or 400 Darko rookies, they can.
And so I'm excited because
it's something I love,
something I understand, but
I'm in a new era in my life.
It's not about the million dollars
that I'll make in flipping
cards in the next three years,
and I will,
it's about
the tens of thousands of
kids that I'm going to impact
who are going to make a hundred
thousand bucks in profit
in the next two years,
instead of raising a million
dollars and losing it.
And that I'm excited about.
I'm excited about pushing
people and teaching them
how to make money
instead of raising money.
And raising money has become
the sport of entrepreneurship
in this era, not making it.
And it's something that I'm
trying to bring conversation to.
- [Katie] So are you
guys flipping cards too?
Throughout his career,
Gary often made pivots, but
then he started VaynerMedia,
which then led him to go all in
on his personal brand in 2014.
My name is Staphon.
I've been at VaynerMedia since
November, 2014, I believe.
And during that time,
I've started out on Gary's team,
working on team Gary with Drock
when it was just me and him
pumping out videos.
And I've since then
transitioned to Vayner talent,
which is basically what
I was doing for Gary,
what the team was doing for Gary,
we do for other people who want
to build their personal brand.
- By the way, Staphon...
Let's show Staphon.
Trying to get some ladies out of this.
Why not?
This is so ridiculous.
Get down here Staphon, I
want you to work with me.
- I mean,
I think one of the things
that you learned early on
being on Gary's team is
to not be comfortable
doing the same thing all the time.
That like starting out,
there was "AskGaryVee"
then it moved to DailyVee,
then it was like,
we just want a bunch of
clips just to put out clips.
And then it was just like,
just kind of always having
to think about what was next.
I mean,
the good thing with Gary is
that his mind was always there.
So you would just kinda like, okay, cool.
And then you try to get ahead of it
to try to present him with stuff,
but you learn pretty early on that like
there's always going to be what's next,
which kind of made you comfortable with
just kind of always being on your toes,
always being ready to
adapt and do something new
and to not get stagnant,
and not get comfortable
doing the day to day stuff.
- It's so obvious to me
what's going to happen
with DailyVee on Snapchat,
like
our execution, these next 12 months,
it's gonna be so fucking crazy.
- I thought that DailyVee was
just going to be like a name,
not like we're going to do it.
It's going to be like a DailyVee,
just kinda like more frequent,
like not necessarily a DailyVee.
So when it was happening and going on,
so Drock was pretty much
responsible for shooting it all
and then turning it around.
And then, so, you know,
that responsibility kind
of shifted to me too.
It's kinda Drock will shoot
it and I will edit them.
And in beginning, it's like,
Oh, this is like a real thing.
This ain't no joke.
This doesn't,
this isn't just something to do on a...
A couple of hours because these DailyVees
weren't two and three minutes long.
- This
This daily vlog has been such a big deal.
- [Man behind camera]
Why did you say that?
- Just put that part there.
- Yeah, it was definitely
like a transition.
I'm just like, Oh, like it
was a little jarring at first,
but then just like anything else,
you figure out the cadence and figure out
how to make it work,
and then you get into that flow
and then you just get it done
until he changes up the format again.
And then you're like
doing it all over again.
But it's just like,
you kind of get comfortable
with the change.
- [Katie] Being comfortable
with change is not always easy.
Let's take it over to Tyler Babin
and hear why he made the
change to leave VaynerMedia.
- My name is Tyler Babin.
I worked on team Gary
for about three and a half years total.
Started in may of 2016,
was a big editor for just
Instagram and Facebook clips,
and then Drock and I
ended up alternating days
and we were both traveling
all over the place, filming DailyVee.
And then I left that
position about a year ago
to kind of just go out
and do my own thing.
- I'm gonna miss you, bro.
- I'm gonna miss you too man, a lot.
- It's super surreal.
I'm really happy though for you man.
- I appreciate it.
- I really feel good about it.
- Yeah, I do too.
It feels like the right move right now.
- I think that's the right sentence,
the right move right now.
- There was a video that
I made at one point,
it's called "99% happy".
And Gary had done a whole speech
where he said he was 99% happy in his life
and 1% being unhappy made him
literally change everything.
- On my 30th birthday I was driving
from New York to Jersey to the store
and realized I was only 99% happy.
That 1% maybe changed my entire life.
If you're not 100% pumped every second,
if you actually are happy it's the weekend
or are pumped to go on vacation,
your shit is broken in.
- And I felt myself creeping
way above 1% of my life
being unhappy, and I
said, all right, cool,
it's just like, it's time to
leave and do something else.
And I knew that I had
built up enough equity
and enough relationships that I wasn't...
No matter what happened
like I didn't think
I would ever leave on bad terms
and I don't think I'm
on bad terms with anyone
in that building.
And so for me, being
able to like step away
and just say like, you know what?
I need to like feed my soul for a while
and do the things that are on
my mind is really important.
And so I think that there's
never a wrong thing with
realizing once you have the
thing you wanted so badly
that you can change your mind
and go a different route.
Nothing's perfect.
You can always go
backwards and you can like,
life is not a linear thing.
You can move up and down and
like go different directions.
And so just being willing
to embrace that I think
is where you will find
like actual true happiness.
- I always play this out.
Let's say, when you go to heaven,
they can show you what would have happened
because that's the only
way you'd ever see it.
Let's just say,
what people don't understand is,
Oh, Basha you made the wrong call.
You should have went to grad school
instead of that
opportunity or this company
instead of that company.
But you'll never believe it.
If you would have went there,
you would have excel...
You should've went to VaynerMedia,
not there, but it's terrible.
You actually went to
Vayner and it was perfect.
And you rose like a Phoenix
and you were the head of all sound
and everything went great,
but then you had to go
to Virginia on business
and you got hit by a
car and you died at 31.
So to like look at two
ideas and think you can
practically make a good
decision is laughable,
literally flip a coin, just
pick the one that feels better
right that second,
and make it about you,
because usually what kids struggle with
is the decision they want to do
versus the decision that they
think they're supposed to do
based on the other voices.
- [Katie] Do you remember India
from the "AskGaryVee" show?
She's going to talk about
her relationship with Gary.
So let's see her side of the story.
- India.
I think it's time to get into the...
- Show.
Let's get into
- The show.
- Oh nice.
India, wait a minute. How
do we not talk about this?
Because we talked about it in real life.
You know, Vayner nation,
look at this,
I mean, India...
Talk about kissing up to the (mumbles)
(laughing)
- My name is India.
I worked at VaynerMedia
from 2012 until August,
very recently, August, 2019.
I started as a community manager in 2012
and worked my way through
a bunch of different roles
at the company but got to
work with Gary for a few years
as his producer and copywriter.
And then just before I left the company,
I was working on Vayner
talent as a creative producer.
One big thing that's very personal to me
that I changed about
myself working for Gary
was my confidence just in the workplace
and being able to sit
in a room as a woman,
working with a lot of
men and state my opinion
and stated very strongly and be confident
in my own abilities.
I think that's something
that I really struggled with.
Vayner was my first
professional job out of college.
So I learned a lot working there
and I learned a lot of
really important skills,
but that was one that I
didn't really totally develop
until I was working directly for Gary.
- Zoom in to my ear.
Right.
The ear is the key in this scenario
because the truth is,
the way to push somebody
above their limits
is to actually have individual
conversations with them
about what is their Holy grail, right?
Like what do they want to accomplish?
Like India and I...
I have a good feel of some
of India's longterm career
ambitions.
And like that gives me, first of all,
her knowing that we've
even had that conversation
in and itself gives her a
little bit more confidence
to work harder because she's trying to get
what she wants out of it professionally
and knowing that I'm the
person that can most likely
make that happen,
at least in the context of this world,
that just even having the conversation,
puts her in a better spot.
- One of the meetings I
had with Gary a Little bit,
the first time I talked to
him one-on-one I was like,
you know, I didn't study
marketing in school.
I studied painting.
And he was like, I didn't study
marketing in school either.
And I think he really helped
me change my mindset about that
and realize that it doesn't really matter
what you did before and you
start to focus on what you
want to do right now and
move ahead with that.
- There's nothing you should do,
you need to focus on what you want to do.
Just because somebody else says it's good,
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- What you should do is look
yourself in the mirror and say,
what do I think I'm decent at?
And what do I like?
And do one of those,
and if you're lucky enough
that what you're good at
you like, then it's
really fucking the mood.
- [Katie] If you shoot for the moon
you'll land among the stars.
So here's Alex,
Gary's executive assistant
for the last two and a half years.
She's going to share her perspective
on adapting to the current task at hand.
- Vayner nation, Alex's here.
Alex.
- I'm, Alex Raffington.
I started Vayner, August of 2016.
I started working for the
office team at their front desk.
I had a friend that
actually worked at Vayner
and I kind of wanted to
get into the agency side,
and I used to work in a bakery previously.
And it kind of like fall
into that rut of just working
somewhere for so long and not
actually like kind of going
for the job you actually want.
And
he was like, this is maybe
like a good first step for you.
So I started on the office team.
I worked there for about
almost a year and a half,
and then talked to Tyler.
He was the assistant at the time,
and he definitely needed some help.
And then I moved up on team Gary.
I moved into the spot of being
Gary's assistant as well.
So I've been working that
for two and a half years.
- I adore Alex, right.
I'm looking right at her,
but in the last week or two there's things
that I've told her that
I want done better,
and I hope she would tell
you that I'm not yelling,
I'm like trying to deliver with honey.
Even you agree, when I come
with you with something,
I'm almost being a little passive.
- Being an admin comes
with structure in process.
And that's a part of like being an admin,
but just know that if you
have to pivot that's okay,
or if the structure that
you created for yourself
is too rigid, then just
back away a little bit
and just know that it's okay
if something doesn't work
anymore and you have to pivot,
it's not that you're not a good admin
or you're not working
to your full potential.
It's just that things just change.
- The game is changing quickly and often.
And if you're not adjusting,
you're going to lose.
The 85 bears, one on a system
that doesn't work in today's NFL.
So you just gotta keep evolving
and if you don't, you lose.
And that's the evolution of my game.
So advice that I gave in
jab, jab, jab, right hook
would have looked differently
today about Twitter
because between time I
wrote it and this minute,
the game has changed.
- So just know that it's okay to change.
It's okay to kind of move things around,
but also ask questions.
That's the best thing for
you to do is ask questions,
so then you can make the
best decision going forward.
- We change our mind seven times a month.
I constantly shit on my
own self once a week.
Like I emphatically on Monday,
say, it's all about this
and literally next Tuesday
go, if we ever do that again,
I mean, this is real life.
This is the truth.
- You know, we always
joke like the admins,
a lot of times he'll come up,
we'll get on the phone and I'll be like
new rule, new rule, new rule, new rule.
And like, it's like a big kind of thing.
- Can you text Tyler and say new rule,
I mean, that's serious.
New rule.
Here's literally how we're going to do it.
New rule, no more.
- And then three days later,
something comes up that proves
that it wasn't that smart
and yeah, we don't need
that new rule anymore.
And most people are like,
there's some fatigue to it,
but only if you
put so much weight into like
the rigidness of systems
and processes.
I always say that process
and systems are there to take
thoughts out of things.
And the second I get to
habitually ingrained into process,
how you take notes, how
you do your to do list,
how you organize your email inbox,
like there's efficiency to it,
but at the same time,
once you rely on the
process over the thought,
you just become attached to the process,
it takes a lot of thinking
out of the situation,
creativity out of the situation.
- You better keep your subjectiveness
and your ego at the door
because that slows you down
and it doesn't make you do,
you better fucking move.
- So I'm always,
once I get too close to just
like relying on the process,
I try and break it and change it up.
- [Katie] If you're
relying on the process,
and having a tough time
accepting the change mentality,
what you will discover is that
most systems will get broken
as well as other projects along the way.
Let's hear one of the most recent stories
about how we went all in on a project.
- I'll laugh and think about the moment
that we pitched him on interrupted
by GaryVee as a new show in format
and we spent a lot of
time on thoughtful designs
and positioning on that new show
and we did one episode and he decided
he didn't want to do anymore.
- I'm changing the name of Interrupted by.
Yeah, because like reading the comments,
I just don't...
I think it triples down on
something I don't want it to,
so the reality is that
show's now canceled.
- I think that's just a great example of,
he could have continued to do it
because we put this emphasis on it,
but he didn't really felt like
it wasn't the right thing
to do for his brand,
so he stopped it.
And I think our team does a
great job on being unemotional
about those changes and
continuing to learn and evolve.
- Unemotional decision-making
is what has allowed me
the great luxury of
standing at this table.
It's not a table.
Fuck.
(crowd laughing)
I'm comfortable in chaos.
That's my happy place.
People are like how don't you drop balls?
I'm like, I drop a shitload of balls,
except some people like to
have two balls in the air
and not drop them.
I like to have 73 and dropped 13.
I like the net of that.
My dad used to get so pissed
when I was building wine library,
he would always be like,
fuck he's like, he would
say like three months ago,
you said Ricky was going
to be the best employee.
I'm like, I changed my mind.
He shit fire him.
Or he's like you said,
sparkling wine was important
now you just eliminated
it from the key spot.
I'm like, I changed my mind.
Like my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest
asset as an entrepreneur.
- I was as bout as far as
you could be down the process
of moving to London with Eric Fulwiler
to help open our office there.
And we were in the office,
It was like about a month away to move,
and that's a pretty big move.
I was 25 at the time,
24, 25.
I was getting ready to move over to London
with a team of five
and Gary just calls me into the office and
asks if I want to be his assistant.
And there was like, kind of like,
well, aren't I doing this?
And he's like, well,
it doesn't have any impact,
like meaning yes,
but this is something
new and new information,
a new situation, a new data.
And
not necessarily not taking into account,
but not letting, just because
that is the case effect,
that aspect of taking that role was
the first like real eyeopening thing.
- And you don't feel,
you don't think twice
or feel bad about it,
something like that.
- No
because when I make decisions,
I'm making them at that
moment and things change.
If I email my direct reports,
my leaders tomorrow and said,
we're now selling actual honey,
but we are no longer an
agency, we now produce honey,
I just bought a honey farm in Pasa Robles,
and we now sell honey
and I just think 80%
of them be like, okay,
like what, what am I doing?
Like, yes, comma.
So when you build culture
and you build trust,
you can go fast.
- And so when you put a plan in place,
or if you're a leader and you
say we're going to do this,
and everyone says, cool, I'm ready to go
and then you realize that
that isn't the right thing,
most people are probably scared
that people are going to judge them
as a flip flopping leader,
if they believe that that
then is the right thing.
- Be binary about your decisions.
Let me tell you what I mean by that.
Don't overthink jumping
into your first job
and then quit it the next
day if it doesn't feel right.
It's not a end all be all if
the first one's not right.
That doesn't mean you can't
be thoughtful along the way,
It doesn't mean that
you can make a decision,
you're doing it and then a
couple of weeks didn't even know,
three weeks earlier, it seems so, right,
you're like, wait a minute,
this feels like a waste of time.
And then even if you declare
it to your whole world
that you're doing this,
people fear changing their
mind out of judgment.
- And then you start to go down a path
that just gets too caught up
where you're too far away
from being able to say,
actually, no, this is the right thing.
I've been presented with
new information, new data,
and I'm making this decision.
And communication goes into a lot of that,
but there's this kind of
it's happening right now.
Like, are we supposed to
do what's best for us first
or best for other people
even if it's at the detriment
of our own self?
- [Katie] Though it seems like the ability
to change your mind as instilled at birth,
This is something you need to work on.
Let's hear from Gary's
brother AJ on his mindset
at an early age.
- I've actually really shifted.
I think that I naturally growing
up was a bit more focused
and put a lot more energy
and put a lot more stock
into your original thought and opinion.
And I thought that if
you change your mind,
then it just validated that
your original opinion was wrong.
And so because Gary is so
willing and able to change his
opinion in mine,
I think there was...
Gary and I really don't
have a lot of friction.
- AJ and I, because of our age difference
have almost a brother father
kind of thing going on.
That's very kind of unique and special.
And we've been,
we've met so many people that are 11 or 12
or nine or 10 years apart
and don't have what we have.
You know, it's tough.
I mean, I was out of the house
when he was seven, right.
And so it's just a very unique thing.
And we have a very,
very, very special bond.
- We've nearly never fist fight
and have never fought over business.
If we ever fight it's
over the silliest shit,
it's stuff like board games
and pick up basketball, right.
- I once punched my brother
AJ on a basketball court.
And I've never really said it
because I don't want to
admit it actually happened.
- But when there was
friction in the early days
was probably centered a little bit around
the changing your mind concept.
And I think what I struggled
with the most was how
constant it was and how effortless it was.
It kind of almost,
I think what I struggled
with was it almost
invalidated the original thought
and made it really tough for me to accept
and receive initial thoughts from Gary.
He would say something and be like,
well, you're just gonna change
your damn mind tomorrow.
Like, why should I even receive this?
Why should I take this seriously?
But I think as I got more
exposure and more experience to
business and life and people,
I grew to appreciate it a lot more.
And I felt like I needed a shift
and it wasn't necessarily a
conscious effort.
I didn't say I need to be
able to change my mind more.
I need to be able to change my mind more.
I think it just came from experience.
And I think it speaks a
little bit to the idea of us
starting businesses and things like that.
And whether it's starting a business
or starting an initiative
within a company,
I think that
ultimately if you fail or
if something is inaccurate,
it's okay.
As long as you adjust.
And as long as you adjust
towards the positive.
- This has been historic.
Like factories,
factories had to adjust to machines.
Farmers had to adjust the tractors.
Retail stores had to adjust to registers
that were computers versus cash.
This is not complicated.
This is historic.
Here's the punchline.
The market is the market.
What is the 54 year old going to do?
Adjust
or loose.
- [Katie] Something Gary likes to say
before giving advice is,
I never think I'm right,
because Gary knows he's just
stating one man's opinion.
In this next chapter,
we're going to dive into
different perspectives
on the topic.
- Tell me how to save my life.
Tell me--
- I'm gonna tell you right now, Will.
I'm gonna tell you right now my guy.
So this is one of my partner, Ryan.
- How you doing?
- Pleasure.
- Your ego is usually the driving force
behind the deep desire to be right.
I have to be right.
And they say like, be
selective in your battles,
but sometimes peace is
better than being right.
So if you have the ability
to firmly believe something,
and recognized when
you're wrong and admit it
and implement change accordingly,
it means you have macro strength,
not micro stubbornness.
So to say.
- People overthink it.
And they have ego that I'm
the only one that does it best
and nobody's ever good enough.
Go within humility, tell them the truth,
and then if they don't
deliver on it, fire them.
I've watched so many people
that are great at their craft
never build a business because of ego,
that they like feeling that
they're better at this thing
than anybody than actually
scaling a business.
- You know, it's what I did essentially.
Like I was in finance.
I worked for Goldman Sachs for seven years
and then pivoted to be in media,
but women's lifestyle
media as a young male.
And I was laughed at.
People definitely laughed
behind my back being like,
what is this guy doing?
But I knew that,
I just knew that I would
not be happy being in the
corporate America flywheel where it's not
solely based on merit
and I wanted to be part of something that
what I put into it was
hopefully what I got out of it.
Or at least I seal my own faith.
- Winning is happy.
Not making more money,
cause you focused only
on the tech company.
What are you trying to accomplish?
And by the way,
it's okay if that shit changes.
At 27, you might need money
or a boyfriend or a girlfriend.
At 34, you might want to
have more work life balance,
cause you have a child now.
At 41, you might need more money
because you wasted your
money after you had a good...
But like it's okay for it to change daily.
- For me, when moving
from finance to media,
I convinced myself
whether it was true or not
that if I failed that I can
easily go back to finance
even if I took one step back,
I can go back to finance,
get a job, get a salary.
So I think that you need to
think worst case scenario
and are you okay financially?
Are you okay with the lifestyle
you might have to lead
if you do fail entirely?
Do you have a family?
Do you have kids?
Are you single?
Do you have dependence
that you need to make
a minimum amount of money in
order to support those people?
Because that might be
a driving force behind
taking a certain risk.
So I don't think you should...
I don't think...
I'm not saying that you should do that.
It create fear in your mind,
but you need to understand
what your downside is,
what your worst case scenario is.
And that will help give you comfort
because if you can convince yourself
that you're okay with that downside,
you're going to go all in and
you're not going to look back.
- [Katie] Gary likes to talk about
how he missed out on investing in Uber
during the angel round.
What we haven't heard is
AJ's side of the story.
So let's take a look.
- You know, I guess this is a fun example.
Gary and I had the opportunity to invest
in the seed round in Uber.
Gary talks about it all the time.
- My most devastating business decisions
have been predicated at the moments
when I bought my two homes.
I passed,
I've never said this clearly,
I passed on Uber because
I bought an apartment.
If I had just stayed in
the apartment I was in
for one more year, I
would have $400 million.
That I don't have right now.
That's about as basic as I can say it.
- And then they re approached
us for the series B.
And they're like, come on guys,
cause these are personal friends,
like, come on guys,
I know you miss out on the seed,
but it's been a little while
we have really good tracks
and we'd love to have you for the ride.
Right?
And I think somebody that
maybe would be too stuck
in the mud would cut their
nose to spite their face,
and not invest.
But you know, Gary and
I said, you know what?
Let's keep our nose in tack,
let's bite the bullet.
Let's forget about our regret.
Let's move forward.
We don't wanna regret twice,
it's better late than never.
And so we ended up investing
in Uber in a series B
and did really well because of it.
Could have done better at the seed,
but that's life, you take
your losses along the way.
The single biggest reason,
Vayner X got to where it got to,
beyond Gary's brand equity
and a salesmanship and
his and his public brand
is our disproportionate willingness
to communicate top-down.
And so,
spending the time and energy
to talk to your executive team,
as well as your entry level employee,
that just started two weeks ago.
- It's about people,
when you go from one to five locations,
it's about the people.
- And I think just having an
authentic line of communication
and an open door policy
that people actually
believe to be true is massively important
when shifting through change.
- [Katie] Being the bigger person
is not always the easiest thing to do.
Let's hear from Marc
Yudkin on how Gary shaped
his perspective on this.
- I'm Marc Yudkin.
I'm our chief operating officer
and general counsel of all of Vayner X.
I've known Gary for
about 13 to 14 years now.
I did a lot of his legal
work as outside counsel,
before VaynerMedia was formed.
I did his investment
work in Uber and Tumblr
and Twitter and Facebook
and all that stuff.
So I was the lawyer for those deals.
So I've gotten pretty
good insight into Gary
for the last 13 or 14 years
and it's been a fun ride.
I tend to be, I tend to
think I'm usually right,
because I usually am,
but it's been harder for
me to sometimes bite my lip
and kind of be the
bigger man and walk away,
even though I know it's
the right thing to do.
And I think he has taught
me that sometimes there's
a greater benefit to even
though you might be right
to just kind of walk away
and be the bigger man
in a situation cause the
benefits derived later on
will far out seed the
advantages now of saying,
Hey, I told you so
or Hey, I'm right now
in this particular case.
So it's not a particular instance,
but I definitely think it's
a particular character trait
it was tough for me at first.
But to realize that in the end,
it's always better to
be the bigger person.
- It's one of the things that
I'm spending a lot of time on
one that a lot of people
aren't capable of executing,
which is how much better life
is when you're the bigger man
and woman in every situation,
no matter if you're right or
wrong, no matter what it is.
Are you capable of swallowing your pride
and having the humility
to say you're sorry
even when maybe it wasn't
yours to say you're sorry?
Leadership and happiness
really really really comes
at the ability to,
to focus on one move, which is,
can you be the bigger person?
For example, being a good
number two, three, four
at VaynerMedia is pretty simple.
Like I'm going to care if
you're capable of being
the bigger person.
Empathy.
A leader that leads positive energy.
Like you're not...
Like you can sell trillion
dollars in my company,
if you're a dick face
you're going to lose.
- Changing your mind shows growth,
changing your mind shows vulnerability
and vulnerability is one of
the strongest things that
you could have these days.
I mean, everybody is so
guarded and so defensive
and you know, I think right now,
especially we're seeing a huge
moment where a lot of people
are being asked to change their mind,
and you could say that it's
one political extremist and
you're trying to get them all
the way to the other extreme,
but it's not, you know,
it's like people within
even a small faction,
just asking for a little mind shift.
And I think that
that shows tremendous growth
and an ability to really become
malleable and allow yourself
to be shaped by experiences
because we are shaped by our experiences.
The person you are today is shaped by
what you experienced before.
So why shouldn't you change?
Your life is not static.
Your life is never going to be
the same thing over and over.
So to expect yourself
never to change your mind
and never change at all is
completely unrealistic anyway.
- [Katie] Gary believes that speed
is one of the most important things
an entrepreneur needs
to be comfortable with.
Claude Silver, VaynerMedia's
Chief Heart Officer,
talks about how speed is
crucial to VaynerMedia success.
- As of this announcement,
the next most important role
in this company underneath me.
And so it's a big one. So as
of today, starting on Monday,
we now have a chief heart officer
and that chief heart
officer is actually here.
So I think we should grab
our chief heart officer.
(crowd cheering)
- You know coming from the
larger advertising agencies
that I was at for years and
what seemed like centuries,
things go slowly.
Change takes a very long time.
And there are a lot of layers and levels
and a lot of T's to cross and I's to dot.
And one of the things that
was very apparent to me,
year one at Vayner is
that we go fast here.
We go faster than fast.
I mean,
I believe that we actually create speed.
- Speed is the game.
And if you can't execute
fast, you can't win
because by the time you
execute on your promise,
the world fucking moved on.
- So I really had to learn how to jog
and be very comfortable in a jog
and then know when I needed to sprint.
And now I'm so used to it
that I actually expect other people
to be able to sprint
just like I'm sprinting.
And I have to realize,
and I'm sure Gary has to
realize this every day,
not everyone is going to be
where you are all the time,
which lends itself to patients.
- I know I'm onto something
so fundamentally different,
and I know that I can
inspire people to do it
cause it's going to have
the empire part too.
See that's what people don't get.
The reason I'm going to win
is because I've got both.
The honey part means that you
want to go change the world.
The empire part means
you'll do it at all costs.
I'm neither.
- So really being okay
with where people are,
being patient enough, feeding
and nurturing them enough,
encouraging them, leading by
example so that they get it.
Because when someone
finally gets that speed
of how we do it at Vayner, they get high.
It's an amazing feeling.
- Like we spend so much time
overthinking instead of doing.
Do it, then know, then the decide.
Speed.
It's all speed.
Like you gotta go fast.
That's how you get shit done.
That's how you figure stuff out.
- Speed without control is reckless.
His speed has control,
meaning it's either been a hound process
as he's done it a hundred times before,
so therefore he can.
Let's say he's evaluating
the company they invest in.
Well, he's invested in hundreds, right?
So he could tell in 15 minutes
if it's the right company or not.
It looks like an impulsive invest,
but it's not an impulsive investment.
He's got the hound up for years.
- I find it super fascinating
that people think fast
decisions can be reckless
because they themselves tend
to question their decisions
and they're imposing their
insecurity as judgment on others
who have pattern recognition,
experience, conviction,
and competence in decisions they make.
I make very fast decisions
when I have all the data
and I have full confidence in my decision.
I make very slow decisions
when I don't have the data
or I haven't figured it out yet.
Demonizing fast decision making
as reckless as laughable.
The judge of that tends
to be the insecure.
- [Katie] Some decisions
don't take a lot of strategy.
Just to gut feeling.
In this chapter,
we're going to see how
entrepreneurs can be more conscious
about using intuition and gut decisions.
- So there's something that
Gary used to say a lot,
that the magic is in the great.
- The world is great.
I play in the great
cause the world is great.
- And I think that really just comes
from the spirit of always
being ready to pivot.
And whether that's because the marketplace
is telling you to pivot
or it's culture telling you to pivot,
or it's Gary telling me
directly that I need to pivot
or me telling him that
I think we need to pivot
on something,
gives that both core strength,
but then the flexibility to
just roll with the punches,
get stuff done and really
harness the power of your gut
as opposed to sitting and
waiting for things to change.
It's very much the be the change
because you're smart and capable.
- Everybody's so absolute.
World is great.
- I think the interesting thing about Gary
and all good leaders is
just clear communication.
So when Gary really feels
strongly about something,
when he is like, trust me, six months ago,
we are going to double down on Tiktok
and here are the reasons why,
you trust and you
definitely fall into line.
And there are other times that he's like,
I have reading tea leaves and whatnot,
or like reading the
marketplace or conversations,
like I'm feeling something,
now tell me how that
will work in this place.
He's also open to that.
And then the third,
he'll definitely be in a conversation,
and you'll say like, actually Gary,
we're seeing like the opposite happened.
And sometimes he's like, I don't care,
screw it, we'll write our own feature
and sometimes he's like,
Oh, super interesting.
Okay, disregard what I just said.
- But if you're sending your ways
and you're not open to others' ideas
or other thoughts or other's opinions then
immediately that they say
something and it's, Oh,
your opinion, different
than mine, you're wrong.
I think that is a terrible way to be.
And I've never been that way.
And obviously you mature and get better.
And Gary was a major part
of that, where you see him,
he has that mentality where
everybody's opinion is allowed.
There are no bad ideas.
There may be bad ideas,
but I still want to hear your bad ideas.
So I think it's being
open to changing your mind
on all things that really matters
and not just kind of changing your mind
or being set in your ways.
I think the openness, the
thing is what really matters.
- When people hear in the ad world
two to 4,000 pieces of content,
they think it's schizophrenic,
they think it's throwing
it up against the wall,
they think it's not quality.
There's a lot of negative
connotation on it
in the creative space,
which is too bad because I
actually think the thesis
that I'm talking about is going to be
the golden era of creativity.
- I'm in a discipline that's
very disciplined, right?
There's a lot of process.
There's a lot of ways of working.
There's a lot of methodologies
to the way we approach things.
But I think despite that
I've always gone with
what makes the most sense.
Intuitively like what do
you feel in your heart
and what makes to you as a professional,
to you as a human being,
to you as a consumer,
and I think that that's one of the reasons
Gary and I bonded cause
for as much discipline as we bring to it,
a lot of what we do, this is marketing.
It's common sense.
It's common sense
and with that common sense
comes human intuition
and you have to lean into that.
And I think that I've been most successful
when I've been able to do that.
But you have to go with the
things that kind of feel right
and that really resonate
with you as an individual,
cause I think that that's
where the truth kind of lies.
- And here's the good news.
We're going through this
at Vayner right now.
I'm looking at James and Margiela.
We had this big meeting and I was like,
like in the beginning of
the end, I was like, look,
I'm changing the direction
of our creative output
and our strategic and creative output.
And it's super okay if
you don't agree with me,
cause I know it's fairly rogue.
And so like, come and see me
and I'll get you a job
doing what you want to do
for more money somewhere else.
This doesn't have to be bad.
Back to personal...
I don't want bad.
I just don't want to go to business.
I'm definitely... I'm in
charge of running the business.
So I'm going to change the direction and
you're a hockey player,
we've been playing hockey
and now I'm saying we're
playing basketball,
not everybody's going
to transfer that skill.
And that's okay.
And I think that's what you do.
- [Katie] You can read
about pushups all day,
but until you start doing them,
you won't improve.
In this chapter, we'll hear how
doing always beats thinking.
- I joke about the DMs that I get.
That's Andy, how do I start a podcast?
And I joke because the
answer's really easy.
It's you start?
I think I've really started
to analyze my own actions
and my own thoughts and ideas
and as I've consumed Gary's content
and I watched Gary's content,
there's just such a big
difference between doing
and thinking and pontificating.
I think so many people enjoy
the comfort of thinking
and strategizing and reading
and planning and ideating
versus just jumping in and doing it.
- Enough listening, start doing shit.
Don't be scared.
And if you're scared, find
somebody who's not scared.
Make them your partner.
Like it's action.
It's going, it's doing.
- I think there's lots of people
that want to make changes in their lives,
and they think they're
doing it by planning out
how they're going to have a 30 day diet
and that they're going to go keto
and they're going to have no alcohol
and how awesome it's going to be
and how much weight they're going to lose
versus just immediately saying,
no, I'm not going to
eat that pasta because
now I'm on a keto diet.
It's just implementing
it right then and there,
doing it, starting it, pressing the button
versus planning, plotting, strategizing.
- Fuck you gonna.
Go do it.
Do shit.
Learn, put in the work.
- I think the hardest thing
to do is make decisions.
That's why people don't change their mind.
Indecisiveness is like so brutal.
I think getting past indecisiveness
is the hardest thing.
And that's changing your mind.
Cause a lot of decisions as you grow,
like growth is changing your mind.
So like when you get,
when you're presented with new data
or new experiences where
you've gone through something
and now you know more
and you have to make a decision to change,
most people just don't make the decision.
They're not actively
deciding to not change.
They're just simply
not deciding to change.
- I always hear people
like, should we do this?
Should we do that?
They're crippled by their indecisiveness
and their worries about total reaction.
It's not what you do,
it's how you follow up on that mistake.
It's not how you spill the milk,
it's how you clean it up.
That's really, what's
important in business.
- Normalizing changing your mind
is something that when you're presented
with new information,
you should be really comfortable doing.
So in a perfect example
is what's happening now
with black lives matter and
all the racial injustice.
Like we have new information,
it's okay to change our minds.
It's okay to say,
I didn't know what I didn't
know and now that I do,
I'm going to change my behaviors.
I'm going to lean in more to stepping up.
I'm going to do my part
to be more engaged.
Like it's...
We have to normalize,
changing your mind is a strength
because we get new information
and we live in a 24 hour
real time environment
where if you get new information
and you don't change your mind,
then you're being...
You're disservice to yourself
and everyone around you.
Because I always say like,
if I'm not learning, I'm not growing,
if I'm not growing, I'm dying.
So like, changing your
mind and being comfortable
with changing your mind
means that you're growing
because you're taking in
the new information that
you have been exposed to
and you're actually using
it to do something better.
- I think the important thing is,
and particularly now in
the face of a pandemic
and in the face of a world
that continues to change
and acknowledge things like,
racial injustice and social injustice,
we're realizing that we as
leaders need to be listening
and learning and pivoting all the time.
And where we'll fail, frankly,
is when we think we know the answer
and that we just keep
blindly going down a path
without always checking ourselves.
And I think now more than ever,
we're in this very...
We're in a tougher place
now than we were even
at the beginning of COVID.
We need to be more sensitive,
We need to learn, we need to take action,
but it's gotta be the right action.
And so to me, the, the whole
idea of changing your mind,
it sounds like it's a
negative in our society
for some reason,
it sounds like you're ambivalent
or that you're disingenuous
or that you're,
you're not committed or
you're not intelligent,
but it actually is a strength.
And it's something that
I think if more leaders
could subscribed to celebrating that,
and maybe there's a different
way of even framing up
that narrative, I think we'd
be in a much better place.
- You know, it's really funny.
I always talk about,
don't be in the middle,
don't be half pregnant,
I pull from opposite directions,
I have...
A lot of what is interesting about me is
I see very very different people
associated with my message.
People that genuinely don't
agree on a single thing
politically or socially
because they're hearing
different things from
me and I bounce around
and I'm been thinking a lot about it,
parenting philosophy,
entrepreneurship philosophy,
obviously political philosophy,
like we are pulling
further and further apart
from each other.
People are pulling in
such opposite directions,
yet I feel like there's so many merits
and so many different
nuanced points of view
and I just think that we've
become so one dimensional
and so absolute.
I think we have to start talking
more about allowing people
to change their mind.
I think if we make changing your mind,
something that is put on a
pedestal instead of demonized,
I think that would really help us.
- Gary doesn't believe in
one subjective opinion,
being the person that can
say that idea is the one that
should be executed,
especially if it has minimal
financial risk to it.
It's like do them all and
see what the consumer thinks.
Find right instead of guess right.
And our industry as a whole
is much more guess right
versus find right because
they'll say that it's schizophrenia,
or they'll say that it's
throwing things against the wall
until it sticks or it's not
on brand or whatever it may be
where we don't necessarily
believe in that as much
because we think that the
consumer should decide
what is quality versus
three people in a board room
deciding what is quality based on
what their opinion of quality is.
- And I think a lot about
that now with my content,
which is why am I so
comfortable with trying things?
I posted a video yesterday
that was upside down
on Instagram.
I don't know how many of you saw it.
And then a couple of days earlier,
I made a video where I
just said, like this post,
like 58 times in a row,
and I've been using this hash
tag in the two posts that,
always be testing.
And it's really my way to give you a nod
of giving you permission.
The like like like video did, okay.
The upside down video
yesterday did not do well.
And that excites me.
And I'm excited to spend more
time over the next year or two
of trying things completely left field
to hopefully inspire people to,
what I'm so unbelievably concerned about
for everybody in here
who's creating content,
whether on YouTube or
Instagram or other places
is you've become so
obsessed with the numbers
associated with the posts
that you're not actually
even putting out any more
what you want to put out,
you're putting out what
you know is going to work.
Too many of you are not doing things
because you're worried about
how it's going to make you look
cause you're late,
so you're not starting, which
is always a bad idea, right?
It's a huge thing happening.
I think this...
I'm always thinking about the
sound bite that may help you.
I'm pumped right now
cause I have a funny feeling
two or three were like,
fuck, maybe I should...
I get it.
I understand brand.
I understand shit.
I'm supposed to be this.
And I have less than all these,
but if you don't start, you don't get.
And by the way, cream
always rises to the top.
If you're so good, right?
You'll be there.
- [Katie] Well guys,
you've made it this far.
Thanks for watching until the end.
Now we'll take it over to Gary.
- The thing that baffles my mind is that
people don't realize that
there is no Monday morning
quarterbacking in life.
You can talk on Monday morning
and be upset when your quarterback did.
Sam Darnold, I need you this year.
But in real life,
when you decide to buy
real estate in the Hamptons
and it doesn't work out
or buy a $5 sneaker and become a flipper
instead of a lawyer,
you don't know how your
life plays out as a lawyer.
So you're either an optimistic
or pessimistic person.
The optimistic person
goes and does flip life.
It doesn't work out.
And they realize, well, I
would have been the law thing.
I would have made some more money,
but I would have been so unhappy.
And I'm glad because now I'm this thing.
I'm a teacher in this high
school and I'm super happy.
The pessimistic person
does great in flipping
does a million a year and decides
they're going to be 3 million
a year as being a lawyer
and that's the only thing
they value is money.
So they fucking lost.
You decide,
you decide if you're winning and losing
before it even happens.
So like, can we just once and for all,
make people understand
that they have no idea
that knowing what the right decision is
at the time you're making the decision
is humanly impossible.
(upbeat music)